[Musique]
enfant Valérie benid dans le prénom qui
m'a supplié d'en avoir parce que les
enfantsent plus beau mais tu'en occupes
jamais ENF si si je suis vache le
dimanche soir parfois ça te prend tu
joues un quart d'heure avec eux tu les
bien vous en fous
là juste avant qu'ils aill se
coucher j dans cam redouble
moi c'est une super histoire d'amour
comme deux oiseaux très beau très fragil
qui se
touche du Bou des
ailes Isabelle dans amour je sais pas si
je devrais te le dire peut-être que ça
va te gêner mais tout à l'heure quand je
suis rentré je me suis rappelé comment
je vous écoutais toujours faire l'amour
quand j'étais
petite pour moi c'était rassurant ça me
donnait le sentiment que vous vous
aimiez et qu'on resterait toujours
ensemble dansamille
redouble je vais te mettre
dehors au début tu auras très froid mais
tu vas voir des endroits tu pourras te
réchauffer faut que tu retrouves ta
ruchez bonne
chance encore habillé toi
edit SC dans hly
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Motors monsieur
Oscar il se fait tard il faudrait vous
changer pour votre dernier rendez-vous
maintenant
bien alors comme c'est pas facile en
fait d'ouvrir l'enveloppe parce que câin
par je peux pas ouvrir voilà donc je
vais m'en charger il faut délicatil et
le César de la meilleure actrice dans un
second rôle est attribué à Valérie ben
dans le prénom elle inter une des écoles
futur papa qui va le trouble FAM et s
amis en rant le prénom qu'il don à son
enfantêre un rôleelleait cré sur scè
pour lequ ellea nommé auolère on a pu l'
voir dans la vérité si je je préfère
qu'on reste am comme
[Applaudissements]
Bellec les Invités de mon père Danne
leunny et au théâtre en 2012 dans le
dindon de fedo mise en scène par Bernard
Mura pour une représentation
[Musique]
télévisée merci merci merci vous pourrez
faire un peu de bodybilding chez vous
avec c'est le projet en
fait n pas d'humour Jo pas d'humour non
mais ça fait personne je savaisçon on n
pas respecté les lignes pardon je suis
premier degré excusez-moi je suis trop
ému pour pour comprendre des blagues je
crois j'ai l'impression que j'ai j'ai
juste une une dimension là
euh je
voudrais remercier Bernard Murat en
premier lieu qui m'a qui m'a offert ce
rôle de Babou
euh Mathieu et Alexandre qui qui ont
écrit ce ce merveilleux rôle je je je je
voulais vous dire que je vous aimais et
euh que je suis très heureuse de vous
avoir rencontré je voudrais remercier
euh euh Dimitri Rassam et Jérôme seddou
euh d'avoir tout fait pour que je puisse
faire ce film
euh je voudrais remercier mes
partenaires
euh sans qui évidemment on n rien et et
vous dire quel plaisir j'ai eu à jouer
avec vous euh Judith
elsine Patrick euh Jean-Michel dupuie au
théâtre Charles Berling au cinéma
et et Guillaume voilà je je vous aime
et je
voudrais remercier mon agent jeanf
François Gabard et mon
ami je vais essayer d'être un peu plus
cour je je remercier aussi mon amitoi
calme il faut que je me
calme je voudrais remercier aussi mon
ami Daniel marchudon qui m'accompagne
dans mon travail je voudrais remercier
mon amie Lisa zos qui m'a donné ma
chance au cinéma je vra remercier mes
amis les jeunes les vieux qui me
soutiennent qui m'ont soutenu ces deux
années ont été incroyables pour moi
c'était vraiment l'année des surprises
et voilà et je voudrais aussi je pense à
mes enfants mes deux fils ah non non oui
président jeis d'accord les deux fils ta
chance César et Abraham on en est aux
enfants on en est aux enfants président
voilà je suis fier de vous et et surtout
je voudrais dédier ce César à mon
amoureux depuis 26 ans éc Valaire voilà
c'est pour toi merci
[Musique]
merci